Маріанна живе у місті Фастів, під Києвом. Вона - тренерка із сексуального виховання молоді,
що для невеличкого містечка уже саме по собі дивина.
Маріанна стверджує, що попри активне користування інтернетом,
сучасні підлітки все ще вкрай мало поінформовані про профілактику ВІЛ/СНІДу.
Я вам скажу так, підлітки 13-15 років, 90% не знають про ВІЛ нічого, взагалі, що це.
А якщо десь і чули, то не знають, як передається, як з цим жити, як стримувати
ретровірусною терапією, тобто взагалі нічого не знають. Я вам кажу про наше невелике містечко.
Але коли я виїжджаю на консультації в школах більших міст, там ситуація аналогічна.
Лише відсоток трішечки менший тих, хто нічого не знає.
Окрім того, що Маріанна сама пройшла курси зі секс-просвіти для дітей,
вона також виграла грант, щоб підготувати 12-ох інших тренерок у місті.
На її думку, роботи ще непочатий край. Особливо в маленьких містах,
де теми сексу здаються дітям табуйованими.
У нас немає з ким поговорити дітям. Немає комьюніті, де вони можуть говорити
про сексуальне виховання. Немає лідерів думок, які можуть про це говорити.
Тобто вони бачать лише через інтернет. У мене є досвід спілкування з 8-10 класами,
і потім залишається час на приватні запитання. Я залишаюсь,
і вони мені ставлять запитання, які вони не можуть поставити батькам
чи вчителям з біології чи основ здоров'я...
За словами Маріанни, також у суспільстві досі існує чимало забобонів.
Є діти, які думають, що до 18 років їм не продадуть презервативи.
А є й ті, кому батьки розповідають байки замість фактів.
У мене був випадок, коли хлопчик не їв борщ, бо йому розповіли,
що його знайшли в капусті, і він дивився на борщ, до 10 років, щоб ви розуміли.
І він дивився, що там капуста, і він червоний, а дітей знаходять в капусті…
Сексологиня Марія Губерник окрім того, що влаштовує лекції для дітей і дорослих,
також популяризує секс-освіту через свою сторінку в Інстаграм.
На її переконання, відсутність сексуального виховання тісно пов'язана
зі статистикою ВІЛ-інфікованих.
Є конкретні статистики, роки, коли запроваджували секс-освіту в школах у країні
і потім через 5-10 років спостерігали спад ВІЛ-інфекції. І завжди захворювання йде на спад,
при чому ми говоримо не тільки про ВІЛ-інфекцію, а й про інші захворювання.
А також, звичайно, про підліткову вагітність.
Торік в Україні офіційно зафіксували 251 168 ВІЛ-позитивних людей.
Третина з них не знала про свій статус. Марія вважає, що в Україні існує ще одна проблема.
Навіть коли діти і підлітки знають про контрацепцію, у них все одно відсутня культура
тестування на ВІЛ. Тому при нагоді Марія сама на своїх лекціях влаштовує такі тести.
Плюс щодо ВІЛ-інфекції, у нас існує демонізація. Люди думають, що ВІЛ - все, ти помреш.
Зокрема діти і люди дорослі не знають, що таке тестування на ВІЛ.
Вони не знають, що це швидко, безпечно, безкоштовні всякі такі штуки.
Тому коли у мене є можливість, я просто організовую дітям тестування, щоб вони знали,
наскільки це супершвидко і просто. Що протестуватися можна у сімейного лікаря,
є купа центрів. Також важливо зрозуміти, як часто тестуватися, залежно від того,
чи займаєтеся ви сексом, скільки у вас партнерів.
Ще одна секс-просвітниця Дарина Мізіна акцентує увагу на тому, що сексуальна освіта
в шкільній програмі є. Але вона там неефективна. У своєму подкасті 11-А Дарина
разом зі своєю співведучою розповідає про секс, культуру згоди на стосунки,
засоби контрацепції. Тобто про все, що мали б розповідати в кожній українській школі.
Я читала українські підручники з основ здоров'я, і там, здається, з 4-го класу дітям розповідають
про ВІЛ/СНІД. Але аж до 8-го класу не говориться про сперму чи статевий шлях.
Це все називається евфемізмом "рідини людського організму".
І тут виникає логічне питання, звідки виникають стереотипи, що ВІЛ/СНІД може
передаватися через слину, через ось такі речі. І стає очевидним, шо такий підхід неефективний.
Дарина також має блог у ТікТок, де розповідає про фемінізм, права людини
і сексуальну освіту. Дарина завела його тому, що їй самій бракувало якісного
українськомовного контенту. Більшість інформації Дарина дізнавалася з англомовних джерел.
Усі секс-просвітниці погоджуються, що дітям варто розповідати про статеві відносини
якомога раніше. Тому що іноді інформація про контрацепцію й інфекції,
які передаються статевим шляхом, виявляється вже неактуальною.
Я думаю, це точно має бути до 10 років. Ну ось точно. Бо коли ми розповідаємо
15-річним "дітям" про презервативи - для мене це дивно.
У київській школі 309 відчувають необхідність сексуальної освіти для дітей.
Однак на думку директорки школи, існує брак довіри у такому делікатному питанні
між учителями й дітьми. Тому якісне і сучасне секс-просвітництво
може частково вирішити проблему.
Ви розумієте, це така тема, що формат уроку для неї не підходить.
Тут треба більш тісне спілкування і, напевно, не з учителем. У дітей існує певний стереотип,
що це вчитель. У вчителів існує певний стереотип щодо того, чим вони мають займатися з дітьми.
І тут потрібна якась інша, неформальна ситуація, інша людина, якій можна довіритися,
з якою можна поговорити і яка може подати цей контент дуже грамотно, послідовно.
Без певних якихось попередніх знань не можуть бути наступні знання.
Не якимось вихопленим шматком з підручника. Тому, звичайно, для нас дуже важлива
участь громадських організацій або на якомусь іншому рівні у статевому вихованні, починаючи з першого класу.
Поки що, ініціативи щодо секс-освіти надходять лише від активістів.
А там, де їх немає, базових знань про секс і стосунки у дітей значно менше.
Тому, переконані секс-просвітниці, якщо держава не візьметься за грамотне втілення
ідеї статевого виховання школярів, не варто очікувати
стрімкого спаду у статистиці ВІЛ/СНІД в Україні.